ми сьогодні моїм викуплять ще один switch
багатий башта незаконним взуттям сьогодні
тут стригу на Верховну Раду України
травня зачитати присягу але обраний
народний депутат України до європейської
солідарність і Володимир Петрович дуже
рада ти з актором центральна ввц
комісія прийняла рішення і ви означало
що Володимир Петрович
я народним депутатом україни замку
всі документи куди параду не в апарат
верховної ради України мій вигляд ніби
мереж до формально rich голова мої
запити цієї дати bully
ось їм це ж псування субин зачитавши 10
виразки чайна формально rich за річкою nikon
і друзів не буду жадібних майбутньому ви
будете іванова сьогодні чомусь
політичні рішення завдань ви буваєте в
зоні щось потрібно дати тільки ти чо чон
і порожнім, а спочатку комусь від
україни тому що й обожнювання вважалося
до дати тату за синій партію рипайся
консультант не баги на собак суть убитий
побачилися зайти до стену
вашу команду і до займаючи вигляд в апарат
українську позицію дикий задоволений ніж у
вас а маніпуляція що армії батька
маніпуляція соток потім маніпуляція я
Ваш успіх виводять ви задавши борошно і до
українцям які захищав екрані ну ніки
накачані богу і вірю і тітку вийдемо ми
сюди сьогодні
ви будете мити від і путіну броньованих
gormiti
вип'є і пояс ви б'єте по метрову
я так такий вас забанити буду за шапку
для вас закінчиться ваша куртка буде з
такий данте я думаю
виду щоб сьогодні готувати приніс
присягу та start button депутату слава
україні
я не зовсім розумій акція харчування королю
це за місія василенка